في الاثناء اعرب رئيس الموانئ والمناطق
الحره في جيبوتي ابو بكر عمر حادي عن قلقه
البالغ من تعرض مضيق باب المندب للتوتر
واكد ابو بكر في حديث للجزيره ان هذا
التوتر سيؤدي الى زياده كلفه اسعار الشحن
وسيؤثر على انشطه موانئ جيبوتي ودعى ابو
بكر لتطمين ملاك السفن والناقلات غير
المرتبطه باسرائيل بان عبورهم من مضيق باب
المندب سيكون امنا
امر مؤسف ان يحدث هذا في البحر الاحمر
ومضيق باب المندب في العالم لدينا خمس
نقاط عبور وباب المندب من ابرزها هذا
التوتر سيؤدي الى زياده كلفه اسعار الشحن
لان بعض السفن بدات الابتعاد عن باب
المندب وهذا سيؤثر على موانئ جيبوتي
وانشطه المنطقه الحره على المدى البعيد
خصوصا في عمليات اعاده الشحن هناك حا
لاقناع القائمين على خطوط الشحن بان
الناقلات والسفن لن تتعرض لهجوم اذا لم
تكن متجهه الى اسرائيل بعض سفن لم تكن
وجهتها اسرائيل لكنها اثرت السلامه ولم
تعبر من باب
المندب